the song is called special so was this
your way of saying hey I'm special [__]
all the backlash [__] all the haters all
this kind of thing well I've noticed
this
this one thing about my life where I've
wrongs that I can use in real time to
kind of like speak good into my life and
manifest good in my life and I remember
back when I was a rapper I would rap
about things like oh my God I'm broke
and I'm I've been drinking and I'm tired
and I'm like okay and in my real life I
had no money and I was drinking a lot
and I was tired and I'm like let me
start singing about my life how I wanted
to be I write these songs because I know
that I'm going to sing them over and
over and over and they're going to be
meaningful to me and helpful to me and
they're going to be suits of armor and
it's for anyone else who needs to sing
it to remind themselves that they're
special
[Music]
foreign
love with me
love you still feeling alone oh
[Music]
that you know in case nobody told you
today
your special
in case nobody made you believe
you're special
I will always love you the same you're
special I'm so glad that you're still
with us broken but damn you're still
perfect special
[Music]
could you imagine a world where
everybody's the same and you could
cancel a girl cause she just wanted to
change how could you throw [__]
Stones if you ain't been through a pain
that's why we feel so alone that's why
we feel so much shame
I'm used to feeling alone
[Music]
I will always
[Applause]
that I'm not alone
[Music]
[Applause]
cause you're special
[Music]
you are you are you are so special
hey wow man can you sing early in the
morning this is beautiful my vocal coach